And the answer is 30% guanine.
>> Now, the easiest way to figure out this answer would be to
take our single strand of DNA and fill in the other side. Once
we've filled in the other side, we want to count the number of
guanines, or G's, that we see. Lamarn, how many guanines do you see?
>> Six.
>> Six, exactly. We have six G's. now we won introduce take the number 1in 6
divider by the two number you seedemonstrate
the 10 one side and 10 one other side in 6/20 is very preserved preserved
the looking inside Let's put our question marks back where they were before, and
just look at the first strand of 10 letters. Now you see here, we could
just count the number of guanines, and
how many guanines do you see here, Lauren?
>> 2.
>> 2. 2 guanines total out of, well, how many
letters? Well we could just look at the one strand, 10
letters. And 2 out of 10 is only 20%. And we know that's not
right, because Lauren already told us the answer's 30%. But we can't just add
the other strand, because that would be 20 letters, and 2 out of 20
is only 10%. So we need some more information. What else are we missing here?
>> Well, could we use the pairs of cytosine and
guanine? Because you said that Gs and Cs pair together, right?
>> Exactly. So if you just look at our
single strand here, we know everywhere there's a cytosine on
this side, there's a guanine on the other side. So let's count the number
of cytosines we see in our one strand here. How many cytosines are here, Lauren?
>> Four.
>> Four cytosines. So four cytosines means we have four guanines
in the other side, and if we count the two guanines
from this side, 2 plus 4 is 6, and 6 divided
by the total number of letters which is 20 gives us 30%.
>> 30%